[Music]
in failed trafficking news oh no
they got caught oh wait [ __ ] is it that
oh i hope it's not that truck in texas
or wherever which one what are you
talking about who's the house right now
dude chill out bro damn bro how much do
you know too much do you know that [ __ ]
was sad though i think i don't know died
in the truck
dude ruined it no this has nothing to do
with a bunch of deaths in the truck that
sucks though dude ryan has assorted
power no this is
this is about 109
live animals found in a woman's luggage
in massive airport wildlife trafficking
what kind of animal 109 why are we doing
all these things of my industry
today there's so many articles of i
bring this up because i know that we
have an expert in the room when it comes
to smuggling and trafficking things in
general and i see that when there are
flaws in the world people need to be
educated it has to do with one smuggling
joe's wheelhouse two wild animals also
joe's warehouse so you could tell us
what the market value women
joe's will house
getting his [ __ ] eaten out by women
big time big time big time how to get
points on your next flight [ __ ] i got
you know i got i got i got laid because
of that story that i told or ada hookers
[ __ ] out and then afterwards a girl was
like
that [ __ ] that should turn me on so much
and i was like oh is that a red flag no
dude that's the right flag she's like
can you hand me a 20 and get on your
knees
and eat this box
i can't believe that brought me so much
game i was paying everyone after that
i couldn't stop cleaning the [ __ ] up
shall i say
20 bucks that's it that's pretty good be
a break already a hundred girls lined up
and i ate them all can you believe that
they're paying me
i must be good at herself gigolo now
dude joe's killing it bro
so two
women have been arrested in thailand for
allegedly yeah thailand
uh
109
for allegedly attempting to smuggle at
least 109
109 live animals in their luggage
including
porcupines i knew it yeah small ones you
knew it no i was thinking about little
small round things some porcupines
armadillos
uh
you know how like people have those
little hedgehog things yeah probably
hedgehogs by a couple of those
you know what gerbils are for what else
they need more animals ghosts you stuff
them up your [ __ ] a couple of [ __ ]
like gekko looking iguana things gekko
looking iguana things yeah all right
anything could roll into a little roll
you know like a little ball yeah
yeah uh
kind of kind of roll into a little roll
yeah i know what he's talking about even
though he doesn't know what he's talking
about armadillos
a little [ __ ] whatever you can shove
up your ass right bart
and the luggage would shove off your
[ __ ] ass you could put it on you can
put a samsonite luggage samsonite here
you think it's stuffing a little
sandwich that is quality luggage yeah
none of that remo [ __ ]
none of that [ __ ] briggs and riley
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] that what's that
lifetime warranty dog you knew i didn't
even know you don't know
do you guys think halfway through this
video joe and bartlett be like so sam's
tonight luggage man
he's promoting his car
you guys ever travel for a living
i do
when i hit this cbd
[Laughter]
right wrong at rocket this is tushy
it's tushy
i do all the time
i wonder who i am and who you are
i know it's a good joke because he does
nothing to say
dress smiles just laughter oh including
porcupines armadillos
turtles yup chameleons he was right
they're all rollers and snakes
how do you know that what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you
those organizer things that chicks love
and little squares little boxes
you just take these animals just roll
them right up and just put them in each
one and then just leave a little hole in
the little zipper and then get a little
straw that goes down so everyone get air
you can share it together
close the rest of it you're talking like
they [ __ ] snorkeled
crazy thing that was the ninth take that
was the best take yeah yeah yeah
for this ad read that was the best take
we had look at hill you knocked out the
park it's got the superstar where's
going
straws are available online you know
calm your smuggled animals down
so the incident occurred at bangkok's oh
man it's hard to pronounce
are you a stroke that's pretty close
i was just gonna say
suvarnabhumi airport and call up tim
asking whatever as two indian women
tried to make their way through airport
security when officials spotted a couple
of suspicious items in their suit and
saw a [ __ ] arm poking out
they were rustling around why is there a
little tail coming out of your [ __ ]
samsonite bag
following a routine x-ray inspection
according to a statement released by
thailand's department of national park
30 skeletons
all these skeletons in there
dude no cap dude that's for a while
that's crazy oh [ __ ] upon further
investigation authorities discovered a
total of at least 109 animals including
two white porcupines two armadillos 35
turtles 50 chameleons and 20 snakes
so who's gonna survive is that the whole
game it's like
how many animals can we kill in here
whole pet store that's what's worth
money like what the [ __ ] yeah that's
[ __ ] were they going to raise like
are they all babies because they're so
small
bro
so you can kind of get contacts in this
photo you'll see a bucket just a bucket
wow ninja turtles but then you'll notice
the suitcase by sam's tonight
in the back and then those green cases
right there as well are holding other
animals are they alive they are
alive i don't know
everything's alive
you know that big [ __ ] machine they
have to throw all the contraband like
stuff into this just like whoop the
[ __ ] animals go in there too
just grind it's gotta go through
wow
so that's like literally just in a case
they're all you know some of the bigger
animals are segregated in their own
basket with [ __ ] straw or whatever
good for them good job and that's
literally how they're put into the
that's [ __ ] wild
they are wild so they weren't supposed
to get through customs is that the idea
i don't know what they were thinking
about the x-ray portion what the [ __ ]
were they thinking like
maybe they're a hookup person that's
supposed to go
like that that guy like called in sick
or something yeah put straw we're fine
yeah dude don't cover them up sensors
i remember one time um we went to the
airport to pick up uh
uh fish from the smuggler um he's a
legit [ __ ] fish smuggler what kind of
fish yeah arowanas asian arowanas
they're illegal arowanas are crazy the
metallic ones yeah the longer yeah but
then the asian ones they're like um
they're super colorful and then they're
like this small red on the fence yeah
but they're illegal in the states i
forgot the reasons why it's probably
because they're invasive not in vegas
apparently because i know someone you
can have an arowana but i think it's
like
it it it has something to do with
southeast asia's like trade laws and
stuff like that and how they take care
of it and it's like banned in the u.s
most people have the silver arowana
which is from south america but it's not
it i don't think it has anything to do
with invasiveness but anyways
a gold one sick looking
dude it might be an agent so we get
there right and then the guy is like i
don't know he's like in his mid-50s
right he has this dyed shoulder-length
hair
and he's trying to look like a boy band
guy right
and then we're waiting in the uh in the
in the whole waiting room and i'm asking
my friend i'm like dude like are we
doing something like i mean illegal
because like these fish aren't supposed
to be here like why are we waiting goes
no no he goes he just wanted it to like
meet here because he's getting the
shipment and we're just going to divide
it at the airport and just go home with
it sounds very naughty and i'm like on
the up and up i know right and i'm like
all right so how the [ __ ] are we gonna
do this and i'm just asking him like so
like
what about the fish and wildlife game
and all that they're like yeah they come
and i'm like so don't they have to check
and like i'm just sweating bricks right
i'm just like this is [ __ ] nuts man i
can't believe this so we're in the cargo
like airport side where they drop off
shipments right we're in the waiting
room
and then the guy he's with this like
lady and [ __ ] and like they're talking
he's just getting restless and he kind
of taps over to her and then she pulls
out
and opens up her purse
and pulls out a little remote control
car
and this dude gets like a little remote
right and this this dude is just laying
back slouching like a child and he's
[ __ ] around with the remote control
car in the lobby just fidget it's just
just [ __ ] running and
a part of me was like yo when am i gonna
get a chance to play right but then the
other part of me i'm just like man this
just feels so awkward like shouldn't we
meet him outward like somewhere else
like like [ __ ] like what if we get in
trouble like we're smuggling illegal
fish right now right
and then the thing comes the wildlife
game guy goes and he looks at the box he
goes how many have or had that many fish
okay and he just checks it off and he
walks away does nothing
like literally nothing he didn't even
look inside no
well well the way the way that they
smuggle this [ __ ] though is they mix it
with other fish cause then they hide it
and if you're if you don't really know
your fish you're just going to look at
and be like okay they're okay
they all kind of like they got drugs or
whatever i don't know right wow
we and then we go to the [ __ ] parking
lot they just divvy up the
the the pets and then we leave and i was
like that was the most [ __ ] awkward
[ __ ] i've ever experienced dude joe if
not for the fifth amendment of the
united states yeah you'd be in federal
prison
for smuggling some illegal fish this the
amount of stuff you're like oh i used to
[ __ ] run drugs i used to run illegal
fish i used all kinds of [ __ ] he's like
i eat hooker [ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ]
that's not illegal steve oh it should be
charity it's a non-profit organization
in prison you should be in the [ __ ]
you should get the death penalty locked
up dude where's your poetic justice
[Music]
[Music]